digamos que fx va a ser igual a 1 sobre
x y vamos a pensar cuál es el límite de
fx cuando x se aproxima a 0 por el lado
positivo y también para ayudarnos un
poco vamos a establecer por aquí una
tabla donde vamos a tener diferentes
valores entonces aquí de este lado va a
estar x y de este otro lado vamos a
tener
efe x y entonces como nos vamos a estar
aproximando a 0 por el lado positivo
digamos que vamos a tomar aquí para x el
valor de 0.1 luego vamos a tener 0.01 y
luego 0.001 y finalmente 0.0001 y ahora
como te darás cuenta esto se aproximan a
0 por el lado positivo y cada vez son
más cercanos a dicho valor y entonces
ahora vamos a ver lo que corresponden si
sustituimos esto en nuestra función
sería uno sobre 0.1 que esto es igual a
10 luego uno sobre 0.01 esto nos va a
dar un equivalente a que tuviéramos 100
1 sobre punto 0 0 1 esto va a ser igual
a 1000 y finalmente éste va a ser igual
a 10.000 esto es simplemente
sustituyendo estos valores en nuestra
función y como podrás observar conforme
x se acerca cada vez más a 0 f x crece
de una forma realmente rápida que hace
de una forma realmente rápida entonces
lo que podemos decir de esto es que el
límite de fx cuando x se aproxima a 0
por la parte positiva tiende a ser igual
a infinito y bien ahora te quiero
mostrar que si de ese lado tenemos cero
puntos 0 0 0 0 1 en total tenemos 7
dígitos de 0 7 7 ceros y de este lado
para nuestro fx vamos a tener algo que
queda realmente relativo o sea conforme
más nos acercamos a cero para nuestros x
nuestra fx tan pequeño sea este número
la fx se vuelve 'relativamente así de
grande y como te darás cuenta
anteriormente ocurría lo mismo teníamos
un cero entonces era 10 tenemos dos
ceros equivalía a 100 y así
sucesivamente
entonces como podrás ver mientras más
nos acercamos a cero del lado positivo
efe diré que se vuelve más y más grande
y ahora vamos a ver que el límite de fx
cuando x se aproxima a 0 por la
izquierda a que corresponde entonces
simplemente le voy a cambiar aquí los
signos a estos valores que ya habíamos
dado antes en nuestra tabla entonces
todo esto se va a volver negativo
negativo negativo negativo y finalmente
estos también negativos y ahora bien si
observas pasa algo similar entre más nos
acercamos a cero por la izquierda
estas cifras crecen pero de forma
negativa y siguiendo más adelante vemos
que además tiende a irse de
incrementando por nuestro lado izquierdo
entonces podemos por acá afirmar para
este caso que nuestro límite tiende a
ser igual a menos infinito lo cual
resulta ser bastante interesante pero
ahora pensemos cómo se comportaría el
límite el límite de nuestra función
fx pero para cuando x se aproxima a
infinito ya sea a menos infinito y a más
infinito
de igual forma hagamos una tabla donde
este lado va a estar xy por acá
fx entonces como nosotros sabemos
nuestras funciones 1 sobre x entonces
cuando x vale 10 f x es igual a un
décimo luego entonces si x es igual a
fd x va a ser igual a 1 sobre 1000 si x
es igual a un millón es f x igual a 1
sobre un millón
entonces si tú puedes observar bien
conforme x tiende a ser más y más grande
en la dirección positiva entonces f x
acerca cada vez más y más a 0 por lo que
podemos decir que el límite de fx cuando
x se aproxima a infinito es igual a 0 y
luego entonces veamos cómo se comporta
el límite de nuestra función f de x
cuando x aproxima a menos infinito y no
voy a quitar aquí los valores de nuestra
tabla sino simplemente también nos
volvemos negativos de este lado y por lo
tanto se vuelven también negativos de
este otro lado aquí es menos 1000
entonces aquí se llama menos 1 sobre
y -1 sobre un millón y como podrás darte
cuenta si observas bien conforme estos
valores son cada vez más negativos estas
cifras tienen a irse también a cero
ahora bien todas estas implicaciones que
tenemos por aquí y que hemos estado
observando hay que tratar de analizarlas
un tanto con la definición formal pero
de una forma intuitiva pues si te das
cuenta los primeros tienden a irse a
infinito y estos segundos que analizamos
es cuando x se aproxima a infinito que
sería lo mismo que decir que tenemos
aquí analizando límites que tienden a
irse a infinito oa menos infinito y en
el caso de cuando x tienden a acercarse
a infinito o al menos infinito por lo
que con todo esto estamos tratando de
visualizar nuestra función f x igual a 1
sobre x con todos estos valores así que
la voy a dibujar por acá quizás quede un
poco pequeño pero creo que voy a
necesitar todos estos valores para
poderla graficar entonces para cuando x
es igual a 0.1 sabemos que fb x es igual
a 10 entonces nos queda nuestro punto un
tanto
por acá y luego entonces para cuando x
es igual a 0.1 0.01 nuestro valor es
igual a 100 entonces como puedes
observar tiende a irse a infinito
entonces conforme más aproximen los
valores de x a 0 nuestra función se
acerca a infinito y ahora hay que verlo
para cuando x tiende a infinito vemos
que nuestra función se aproxima
demasiado a 0 entonces esta gráfica se
comporta de esta manera y ahora también
vamos a observarlo para cuando nosotros
nos aproximamos a 0 de la parte negativa
vemos que aquí tendríamos menos 10 y
tiende a irse a menos infinito cuando x
toma valores muy cercanos a 0
esto es para cuando x toma valores muy
cercanos a 0 y para cuando x tiende a
irse a menos infinito nuestra función
tiende a acercarse o se aproxima
muchísimo a 0 entonces también se
comportaría de esta forma cuando
nosotros nos estamos fijando de las
partes negativas o de los lados
negativos así que como nosotros hemos
dibujado aquí
la gráfica lo que nos dice es que hay
dos asín total y esta sería para cuando
es igual a cero como ves nuestra gráfica
nuestra función se aproxima demasiado a
este eje de las equis pero nunca lo toca
nunca lo toca y es para cuando el caso
de que es igual a cero y esta sería
nuestra a sin total horizontal ahora
bien si tú te fijas también tenemos por
acá una asín total vertical y en este
caso es para cuando x es igual a 0 y de
igual manera nos acercamos demasiado a
nuestro eje de layers pero tampoco nunca
lo vamos a tocar porque cuando x se
aproxima demasiado a 0 por la parte
positiva
vemos que jett tiende a irse hacia
infinito por aquí x se aproxima a 0 por
la parte positiva y tiende a irse a
infinito y cuando x se aproxima a 0 por
la parte negativa el jet tiende a irse a
menos infinito y ahora analizando el
límite de fx cuando x se aproxima a cero
vemos que no está definido no está
definido puesto que tiene dos diferentes
valores por un lado es
infinito y por el otro lado se aproxima
a menos infinito